wo ist dein leben
[Musik]
bevor ich ein restaurant hatte habe ich
lange als koch gearbeitet
in einem bistro das ganz ähnlich aussah
bevor wir das restaurant aufgemacht
haben hatte ich in einer firma als
elektriker gearbeitet
und ich war bankkaufmann nachher
wirklich hätte sich erstaunlich da
arbeiten sie jetzt in einem ganz anderen
beruf aber es hat sich gelohnt auch wenn
die gastronomie ganz schön anstrengend
ist ja gesagt aber man erlebt viel in
der gastronomie
bevor ich den job als koch hatte
beispiel junge in der küche na das waren
zeiten ich könnte ein buch darüber
schreiben
seine biografie will auch gar keiner
lesen was aber vielleicht interessieren
sich die menschen ja für meine erfahrung
sagt wir würden es lesen nicht war max
ganz sicher
zwei käufer haben wir schon habt ihr
zufällig nico gesehen hatte gesagt dass
er einkaufen wollte er ist jetzt aber
schon seit ewigkeiten unterwegs als ihn
die sanitäter gerufen wird habe ich
nicht mehr gesehen du was machst du denn
hier
hallo ich bin's jahre entschuldigung das
muss aber eine verwechslung sein das ist
ja nein ganz sicher nicht das ist otto
aus duisburg ich kenne ihn schon seit
jahren nicht kaufen gebrauchte fahrräder
von ihm ab sagt nicht dass sie rechte -
das würde ich auch gerne wissen
lasst es mich erklären
dinge gingen hin
[Musik]